we've got major new details to share
with you about when millions of
americans
might be able to take a vaccine against
the coronavirus
cbs news has obtained a document from
the government's operation warp speed
and according to their estimates
december 15th
has been marked as a date for states to
start receiving the fisa vaccine that is
two weeks from today
the moderna vaccine would first become
available a week later on december 22nd
now the goal is for at least 20 million
americans
to start a vaccine regimen by the end of
the year and that of course would be
desperately needed good news as the u.s
hits 28 days in a row with more than a
hundred thousand new cases
officials warn it might soon get a lot
worse than that
our lead national correspondent david
begneau is in evansville
indiana david good morning to you
good morning tony look november was the
deadliest month in the pandemic for the
state of indiana
and now doctors like those here at
deaconess hospital behind us in
evansville are worried about the surge
in cases following thanksgiving
look if you're watching this and you're
like i'm so tired of hearing about the
pandemic the rules the restrictions what
they want us to do and not do
imagine being the doctors and nurses who
haven't had a break in eight months
our nursing staff is getting a little
fatigued at this point so this is dr
gina hunky of deaconess hospital in
evansville indiana
she says the ongoing coronavirus
pandemic is taking a toll
on frontline workers and nationwide the
flood of new coronavirus patients
is showing no signs of slowing down
hospitals in new york state are already
short staffed prompting the governor
there to announce emergency hospital
measures
now his plan includes a call for retired
doctors and nurses
to return to the front lines in the new
battlefield
hospital capacity is the top concern to
the west now the line of people
waiting to get a coronavirus test at
dodger stadium in los angeles
stretched for miles monday as cases
across california continue to spike
governor gavin newsom warned that he may
institute lockdowns in the hardest hit
counties
to try and slow down the spread you can
see in mid-december california
the icu beds will be at 112 capacity
you know despite an accelerating crisis
many americans are still resisting
basic efforts to control the virus i'll
resist
and i'm not the only one who will resist
take rapid city south dakota last night
residents debated implementing a
stricter
mask ordinance not a mass mandate after
that state
led the nation in coronavirus deaths per
capita
this month it's just a mask wear it this
is a public health crisis
i don't know what else to say the
measure passed nine to one but some
businesses can opt out
and houses of worship are exempt in
other parts of south dakota some local
leaders are taking no chances
this is a mandatory mask checkpoint set
up by the cheyenne river reservation
one in every four tests here is coming
back positive to slow the spread the
reservation's largest city was placed
on a 10-day lockdown tribal chairman
harold fraser
says the reservation has only eight
hospital beds for the twelve
thousand people that live there and if
you wanna get to the nearest icu
you've gotta drive three hours away our
main priority is to save our people
and just we know that if there is a
vaccine it's going to be a long time
come we as indian people
we're always at the back of the bus on
whatever it is
so i guess we'll just have to wait and
see it
look the chairman told us those
checkpoints are not just for checking
for mass they're for contact tracing
where are you going and when are you
coming back because a lot of native
americans are getting ill
when they leave the reservation to go
shopping for food and they come back
after being in contact with someone the
outside who is infected with the virus
one more thing before we go the state of
ohio the republican governor mike dewine
he's facing articles of impeachment
brought by members of his own party so
get this republican lawmakers want to
impeach him
because they are unhappy with his masked
mandate but the fact that he's put
limits on businesses how many people can
go inside
they say he is abusing his power but
tony right now in the state of ohio
hospitalizations due to coronavirus
are at an all-time high
yeah he feels like he has to do
something and we're actually going to
speak to governor dewine
in our next hour david thank you very
much looking forward to that